and you're very welcome
to i speak a lot of swedish in my videos
and i always see you bros ask me what
does it mean i wanna know
that's exactly how you do it so i'm
gonna teach you 10
very useful swedish sentences that you
can use in any day of your day
yeah i made a video three years ago
actually
teaching some swear words so i guess you
can say it's kind of part two of this
three years later i think i also said in
that video that if i ever reach
100 000 subscribers i would strip on
camera
if i get 100 000 subscribers i'll do it
[Music]
superb i get it
you've never been this turned on but
please put your pants on you weren't
wearing pants to begin with
i probably should have realized anyway
here we go the first word is fun
not fan not like you or like that
it means damn in a more meaner way i
guess all right
say it after me fun
okay that was pretty terrible don't
worry you'll you'll you'll get there the
second word is
it means but in a sentence god damn you
have a beautiful rumpa
or i want to put my face in
in that room
and possibly live there for a while
third word is kiss
now you may think that kiss means this
is
this is not kiss in swedish kiss means
pee in swedish
you have to be very careful if you say
kiss me
then i i am going to pee on you
it's the swedish rules i'm sorry maybe
you like it i don't know
the next word is nipple which in sweden
means brast vota
so say it after me
as in a sentence uh sorry sir
but your breast water is showing please
cover up you dirty dirty [ __ ] alright so
here's a sentence
that if you ever meet someone swedish
you have to say this to them
because it's very flattering and we love
to dance so
if you ask someone to dance the sentence
in swedish is
which is do you want to dance
just ask them that and it will be great
i'm sure you will thank me trust me
this is going to be great another great
word
is uh smarty kopp say it after me hey
guys shut up
durschen sorry so say it after me
head get don it basically means
lubricator
for example in a sentence i am so sorry
i forgot my smart cop could you please
let me borrow yours
the next word is bro bra basically means
good in swedish say it after me
bro as you know means bra in english
and in swedish it means good coincidence
i don't think so
another great word is smurgos torta it's
not a swear word
but it can technically be said as a
swear word if you say it loud and
aggressive enough so say it after me
smurf was torta now a little bit louder
and more aggressive
smurgos torta and even further
smurgusto
it basically means sandwich cake for
example in a sentence
i would like to shove a smurfgross water
in my face
if you're traveling to sweden by car you
might come across a sign
that says i know what it seems like
and we're not that weird in sweden well
maybe some
[Laughter]
it basically means entrance which i know
might
seem even weirder but it that's what it
is
let's just deal with it and move on
another word that is actually a swear
word i say it a lot in my videos i i i
guess
it's better to swear in swedish because
unless you're swedish no one's gonna
know what the hell you're talking about
anyway so
if you're not allowed to swear you can
use this word instead
and it's diabla which basically mean
[ __ ]
so you could say for example now we
learned
javla smurgostota
you are now upgraded as a bro
that's all the words that you basically
need if you are going to sweden or if
you're meeting someone swedish
or if you just are bored and you have
nothing else to do which is probably the
case here
that's pretty much it for me bros i hope
you learned a lot and
i hope you enjoyed this video right now
you can hit like button and you will
have a free smurgos torta just for you
another quick thing is i bought one of
these dog
electrify leashes uh i have i don't use
it on egg
don't worry even though i want to every
time
but since i swear way too much in my
videos i wanted to teach myself
so i figured if i swear i will shock
myself in a video
so go ahead and recommend a game that i
can play for this
because i think i need to learn and
that's pretty much it for me
stay awesome bros here's the brofist for
you
love you bruce